I love this man's work in Deadwood as
sheriff Bullock and then the u.s. deputy
US Marshal Raylan Givens and justified
and back for a second season with Drew
Barrymore on Santa Clarita diet
available for streaming on Netflix
turning tomorrow good to see you Tim
Olyphant sir be here thanks for having
me off come on man I have your bracket
my hands if there is a sharpie straight
line thought a bad one no and then a
highlighted good one straight line for a
good one I mean the the left side of
your breasts not madness is it's not
it's March I know that's that's the bad
part oh you oh my god
you only got four wrong in the Eastern
Mumbai thank you and I had San Diego by
the way I hope you give me some credit
they lost by two they say there that
doesn't work that way sir but come on it
does not work that way but if you lose
by one you lose horseshoes it's like
it's like you lose by 20 or something
like that
but thank you for taking part in these
again no I wish so I tried to get into
now I'm now I'm favoring the walkout
I've changed my tune
I'm very anti in situ n-c-double-a it's
a it's a racket it's it well so you've
gone from bracket to rack it's a racket
you just remove the B yes that's what
it's become good to see you bud it's
good to be seen thank you you thanks for
being here you bet thanks for being here
I have no choice but to be but it's good
to have you here every day just don't
show so um so art do you write you ask
that question oh no no are you no no no
that's because you know we don't talk
about know I'm here um I know I'm here
for you now you you did sports talk
radio right I did not amount of punk
rock radio station hold on a second yeah
so what was the name of this show on the
punk rock radio station well it was the
morning show on Indy 103 here Joe
Escalante my good friend Joe Escalante
bass player for the Vandals mm the Great
Southern California punk band he did the
morning show David Lynch did the weather
you mean the director that's the one are
you serious that's the one like twin
peaks' did he do the weather um
here's the here's the couch dark and
gloomy he was a catch he only did the
weather for the moment that he was
speaking they didn't understand it this
is not necessarily true he would call in
and he would say he'd say this is David
you know with the weather and then he'd
say all right now it's it's very wet
gray and the thought of the day you know
an ad of the Father day you know and
then there's Dan mountains fountains
sound rich and then he'd that was it and
then Dennis hoppers in the background
with you know with an oxygen mask
threatening not to have anybody look at
him right and then I came on I did
sports well what were you like as a
sportscaster were you it was it was hard
to it was hard to explain but I might
Joe and I found it endlessly
entertaining and okay but on the other
hand that that radio is shows no I would
have the attendant have the newspaper in
my hands and I would just read from the
from the paper oh okay or what I
remembered so how accurate so I would
say we it was it was a daily the same
thing daily routine it was it was and it
just didn't wherever I was I would just
call in so if I were if I were here
right now I'd call I'd say you know I
just got a quickly call in and I'd get
on my phone and I'd call in I'd say you
know it was always the same stick I'd
say good morning Joe and then we chat
for a second I'd say let's talk sports
go and then I go you know NBA basketball
Clippers win and then he'd say what
happened is I don't know but I was at
the gym and I'm just thinking yesterday
I was at the gym I saw it there playing
a walk they play Milwaukee this is
literally this is literally how it go I
think they're playing Milwaukee and if I
remember correctly I know they were
winning when I was why on the elliptical
so let's just put it down in the win
column
[Laughter]
in c-double-a basketball it's bulls on
to tennis and then I feel just whatever
really you could do no wrong it sounds
like a Saturday Night Live skit I don't
know what it was but what was fun about
it
that it could be whatever we want it
could be in look to me it was like some
sort of ridiculous create creative
outlet of some bizarre but whether it
was lovely about is that in the other
day you could just it just be
informative and we could talk about
whatever we wanted I mean I could open
up with you know I'd call them from
Eastern Europe and just be like you know
our top story greco-roman wrestling and
we just talked about you know wrestling
in Eastern Europe it was fun and then
we'd say and that my friend is sports
and we close it up and if I didn't give
him any information he often would try
to fill in some gaps okay yeah would you
like me to do that right now I mean we
could we could we could attempt to do
that for us in please well cause I think
you don't mind me saying
yeah the old fan here in the Richardson
show your memory about where you
finished in last year's bracket
tournament yeah I believe I want is it
sad I believe I want it it's a tad fuzzy
first of all let any of the kids at home
that are going into anything whether it
be business certainly sports a short
memory sometimes the key to success you
know I mean you just got to move on take
three steps that points over we move on
as far as I'm concerned I won now what
did you want to talk about okay well
congrats champ thanks for coming back
here and I'm winning now the hell
happened to Arizona great and that
Xavier thing okay I was in listen big
shot here so forgive me but I was in
Asia at the time yes and all I read was
there were some controversial calls
that's all there was it was it the Tim
Olyphant of Southeast Asia giving that
Sports report let me tell you something
anybody here from the NCAA listening
Thailand is pissed
sorry headline cuz if they didn't know
about it they do now cuz I told them and
they were they were passionate lovely
country by the way I have no idea what
happened Arizona I think most everybody
is wondering out in Arizona you Addison
you Arizona is a final 14 yeah don't get
me started on the in situation if I had
done well in the bracket we wouldn't be
going down this road but I didn't so I
just right now the NCAA as far as I'm
concerned that system Terry today
something about instead of one and done
to and none what the hell's going on to
a nun did you information I figured I
could just drop anything was on the
elliptical oh my god you know about some
kid in San Diego that's gonna do a pro
day today in the rain no no well tell
you that kids Johnny Manziel yeah oh
that's a good one yeah yeah that was the
tease because he he knows you know how
to sure how to make it in the rain you
know yeah you see yeah no I see the
story they died Tim's referring to is
the big the Big East Conference has
recommended replacing one and done with
yeah two or none policy what does that
mean in college basketball
either go high school straight to the
pros yes or you commit to two years to
college yes right I'm sorry but what the
hell's going on with the wait I don't
get it
now how is it helpful to the kid I don't
understand how that helps a kid but that
just means you've got to come for more
than one year that's essentially what
that means that's just another way of
saying you can't leave here to go make
money and yeah that's right yeah I don't
make money for time sir stand I don't
understand it I just don't get it I
don't get why these kids can't make as
much money as they possibly can while
they can I don't get it don't get me
started
looks like we have let me tell you
something let me tell you something I I
see on your monitor there they just
showed Kentucky mm-hmm
every team needs a little something to
put them over the edge okay and Kentucky
there with their cool white checkerboard
and they got kind of that retro 80s like
certain lean and then the kid and play
look some the thing here's the they just
need one little thing to put them over
the edge oh there it is
it's a shoe if they go out wearing those
sneaks vans they're gonna win the whole
thing
don't you think that's all they need by
the way have you come with production
value yeah are you serious a photograph
of a shoe we just came up with that we
call these shoes those are fans way to
go Chris yeah I don't have a childhood I
do have a childhood but I didn't lace
him up like that really Timothy yeah you
didn't know I went out there done the on
the ramp that's why I talked early you
weren't stealing no I realized very
early on I'd have to talk for a living
you weren't on the ramp
you weren't out with your buddies
stealing wood from the construction site
to build the ramp no no no no no is it
by the way the answer to that question
is I was wondering what ramp you were
referring to oh wow okay now he's
showing me falling off of a skateboard
when uh by the way of all people that
I've my god skateboard oh my god that's
so sad you see who I'm falling from yes
I do the greatest of all time
yep the goat himself he was even shocked
by it
did you see how surprised he was that
you went down oh my gosh Wow I'm gonna
put on ice skates later what do you know
definitely not without him rip on coming
we don't have any ice skating here
either
and we're indoors Tony Hawk walking out
so let me tell you they're not what
other production value do you have here
do you have others or is this it oh now
I've disappointed you
go blue okay they get you back on my
side I'm nervous man you're nervous I am
because I'm going to the game yeah and
that's beyond the ordinary yeah and I
don't see that I don't see them
impression so if they lose its I feel
like it's gonna be and I feel like are
you superstitious if I go I mean it's
just it's the stage a boycott I'm gonna
try to get the kids a boycott by the way
that would be an odd thing to just be
out there shot with your spare time if
I'm out there just saying guys don't go
on the court get paid time is now
powerful join together let's go
paid yeah do that do that huh starting
tomorrow around look at your coach
what's he making sit down everybody
let's get it we're out of here we're all
walking that would not be good wouldn't
go you're definitely getting me nervous
on that front are you superstitious at
all no at all never even when you were
an athlete getting ready for I like you
know I'm and I was an athlete I know
yeah well I've got production footage
from my pro day let's take a look at
Timothy Olyphant
your USC days very Sam Donald looking
let me tell you something else has not
even me is you that couldn't be me Wow
radio audience he looks just like Sam
Donald was a big kid by the way put me
out there on the field I'll make it look
good too with Sam his pro day
yeah with the fake guy with the guys are
fake running IG you could spin it in the
rain right that way that's moviemaking
by the way you will see what they are
not even in the tournament I know I feel
like I only put Arizona going deep
because you know it's a pac-12 thing I
want to root for the pac-12 haven't been
an SC guy wrong here to do that wrong
it's when is it the right hearing I know
when is it the right year for the pac-12
to go deep yeah well they lost they even
lost the second round of the NIT
tournament did you miss that in
Southeast Asia the type that the Thais
didn't inform you you know I saw the
whole day - did today yeah you're just
trying to ruin it I've tried right here
this morning I thought your job is to
wake people up and make them happy you
form them and keep giving a little pep
in their step to start their day don't
hate congratulate you're right you know
what I mean I should live that you see
that image you see that image of you
running yes why don't you put me right
underneath it just trampling on me yeah
guys in the back you want to get on
there
get on that I'd like to take a break
we'll come back we'll talk about your
show thank you
okay I appreciate you doing ah and also
I you're very proud of it you know I'm
very funny I can't wait to talk about it
Thank You Santa Clarita diet
right and then you know what I'm you
know what I'm gonna ask about to write
it's about another show that you used to
do and now it's gonna come back where me
we're doing our best I'm giving it the
old about Deadwood for really yeah and
when I say I was about to say to give it
the old college try but you're
boycotting okay college try means we're
all screwed and not getting paid no
one's getting paid okay very good
Timothy all the fan is here when we're
back we'll discuss that and get ready
for Adam rip on and more here on this
busy Thursday show now who's telling
those ice skaters they can't make money
[Music]
still hanging out here season two of
Santa Clarita diet we just saw a clip TV
audience just saw a clip it starts
streaming on Netflix tomorrow Friday the
23rd so ask the poll question of Tim
before we before we glide into
television shows go for it yeah Tim
which favorite most likely to survive
the March BS weekend
Villanova Kansas Duke Michigan Kentucky
no Xavier our are the shoes not just
remove my shoes Kentucky gonna wear the
shoes do we know if Kentucky puts on
those two white shirt even if just Nike
just they could mock it up you know I
mean come up with the checkerboard vans
can't have a saddle put them over the
edge every team needs a little something
it's one game anyone can win you just
need a little edge removing Footwear
from the equation what do you think
removing Footwear from the equation
makes it very difficult want me to box
and Tim you know I don't mean a box yet
what do you think Michigan is probably
the of all the favorites that will get
through I mean true favorites Michigan
being one of the favorites they should
win should and they should I feel like
Michigan for sure if I had to just slide
all my chips all of them right to that
way if I had to put them on they over
there and you would carry them formula
you could have I could put all my chips
I'd give them to you care to put onto
Michigan not right 23% Michigan
33% villanova most likely to us around
the weekend 27% Kentucky 9% Kansas so I
guess they're not think that Kansas
eight nobody's on Kansas if you look at
my side they try I think I do have
Villanova going all the way through you
do which over Duke you have Villanova
over Duke and that's the way you had
Clemson you have Clemson game is here
I'm gonna win this thing back the back
difference me defending champion you
have Texas 10th and Clemson is elite
eight teams I'm telling you I christen
the set of side I it's called it's
called the magic darts oh the magic
darts that's what I throw so santa
clarita diet season to you and drew
barrymore yeah guys are having fun we
just saw a unique family sort of I'm
telling you it's about you know it's
about a marriage mm-hmm it's about a
marriage it's a the if the blood and all
that stuff if you'll enjoy that then
you're great you're good and if you
don't it just it's a metaphor it's a
metaphor what you know when you you know
of like what what you got a do you get
what you gotta do to take to make a
marriage work
got to put in the blood sweat tears
you're talking about it's about a really
think of it this way yes it's a you're
in a long-term relationship and your
wife has decided to make some drastic
changes in her life because that can be
stressful it can cause right a lot of
appeal especially if she's Undead and
people need to make sacrifices in order
to make the relationship work and that I
think America can understand and
identify with because it comes from here
it does from the heart right let you rip
out and eat it's smart and funny hmm
but there's a lot of right here a lot of
the fields and I watch the show and I
dare you to tell me otherwise okay and
you can watch it against season two
ready for streaming tomorrow tomorrow
all right so let's fantastic scale of 1
to 10 mmm
the possibility of another Deadwood is
with 10 meaning your cursing and iambic
pentameter again and one is it's never
gonna happen what do you have I'm
look it's a I tell you what it's it's
it's certainly closer to being a reality
than it's ever been and that being said
I still continue to say it's very hard
to get people together for a barbecue
that lasts an afternoon let alone to get
everyone together for a production that
lasts a month or two is that is that
another metaphor of saying David Milch
is not writing it no no there's pens
bunt pens been put to paper there was a
script it exists there heart there are
there are words there are words and
there and there and they're lovely
they're spectacular spectacular we gotta
do somethin bout those wheels at home so
so a paint a can of peaches has been
opened on the script Oh first of all God
bless you for caring number one herring
are you kidding me I know is a special
thing oh it's fun to be a part of it so
I really do appreciate it so everyone
does and the minute we have left time I
mean what do you think you know we're up
against it the heart out of the of the
radio ours about to hit but what do you
have no III I'm telling you that I just
want you to know yeah and the people
watching home you tell me if I'm lying
I'm doing everything I can to make it a
reality and it is closer to being a
reality and I hope it works out movie or
TV movie well no it would be on I don't
know what anything is anymore but it
would be on H it would be on HBO so it
would be a TV show or it would be a
two-hour movie on that's what I'm your
man by the way not to get confused
Santa Cruz diet tomorrow no it's good
yes so it would be whatever it is
whatever that animal is and whether
these are conversations I don't know
what it is I don't know if it's a movie
I don't know if it's in multiple
episodes these are things that it's it's
in there it's a process thank you for
coming on hey thank you appreciate the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience